welcome to the soup stew this video I'm
playing my Rita from Norway I think I've
played pledging before isn't this a
situation where queen bee six winned
subs on or forces this awkward d for
move I think it is okay so we have a
quite weird hybrid system here between
the Leningrad Dutch and the Stonewall
may be here 93 easy to see but might
provoke some some weakening moves maybe
make some headway here
okay going to this active more active
looking square but the night does not
have any any any root down you'll be six
we should a six yeah let's see maybe I
can get in Bishop a six with the temple
hmm so he's saying that be six is not
winning the night interesting curious to
see how this should pan out I don't need
to take them still don't hesitate still
does not have a square
yeah maybe you can take on d5 and do
something I don't know I go here I
bishop no Bishop f5 is a stupid move I
must go here first two then then he
gains the tempo to get the night back f3
is hanging some um yes should be six
first yeah first let's gain this temple
white resigns yeah that was I was quick
yeah I think this is a decent line this
is the setup with the nerdy only see six
here um chat after the check he is
forced to play this yeah it's not the
end of the world but certainly nothing
that like is very much afraid of and
just play this position I was surprised
that you went to see five I mean it's
probably not bad but just normal 92
looked fine gerrant here well I'm
threatening be six but he just didn't
didn't react to it I expected efore then
I don't know maybe go back to the six or
play be six store it so it's interesting
b6 is interesting yeah it's the tempo
here jump it after that b6 it's just the
nidus is gone can now try a bit but it's
still trapped yeah I thought that maybe
maybe can somehow you make of peace
sacrifice out of it attacking defy but I
can play I'm sorry I can play this first
yeah it's just a piece at the end what
can you do okay thanks for watching